okay the mainstream media push fake news
in two different ways the first way
we're very familiar with they spin the
stories they make up some of the
reporting they exaggerate other parts of
the reporting right that's the first
part is how they report the stories but
the second part of how the left pushes
fake news is actually more important
than that and that is how they select
the stories that they're going to cover
so it's not even in how they report it
it's in the very fact that they are
reporting some stories and that they are
not reporting other stories
case in point great example of this is a
very sad local story the killing of
Ahmad our burry is the big story that
blew up over the weekend
it's got everybody at everybody's
throats and I think pretty much
everybody is missing the point at least
as a matter of national political
perspective what do we know about the
Ahmad Arbor eating two white guys shot
and killed a black guy named Ahmad our
burry the guys were tailing our burry in
a car this is in Georgia the two guys
had their guns out right so they there
were brandishing weapons our burry knew
that they had weapons there was a tussle
for one of the guns and our burry ended
up dead and we know all of this because
one guy a third guy filmed it for some
reason actually that does sort of play a
role in how we think about the case but
that's pretty much all that we know
about it right then predictably
left-wingers pushed this narrative that
this was a modern day lynching that
Ahmad was out minding his own business
out for a jog and these two crypto
Klansmen came up and lynched him then
some right-wingers pointed out that are
buried an arrest record that he had been
poking around a house that was an open
construction site in the neighborhood
and all of which I guess you know tells
us something about the left-wing
narrative doesn't really tell us much
about the case itself though right just
because the guy has an arrest record
just because he's poking around a house
that's under construction in the
neighborhood that doesn't justify
killing him doesn't no I don't think any
of us would say that
so then three questions about the
incident itself was it murder possibly
it was possibly murder but I don't know
that they're gonna get very far the
prosecutors
if they push this idea that it's murder
because if it was just murder if these
two guys were out there trying to snipe
down a black man going for a job they
probably would have killed him sooner
wouldn't they they they had the open
shot they were trailing him but they
waited until he grabbed for a weapon and
then there's this tussle that happens
off-camera and then he dies
is that going to stick as a murder
charge possibly but it's a tougher case
to make also if it was murder they
probably wouldn't have filmed it right
that doesn't make a lot of sense you
don't want to you don't want to film
yourself committing a crime on camera
was it manslaughter that seems more
likely you know these these guys were
out they were being vigilantes they were
following this guy who they suspected of
committing a non-violent crime and so
they didn't actually want to shoot him
but then you know our burry feels like
he's pinned into a corner so he grabs
the gun reasonable thing to do and then
there's this tussle and you know somehow
Barberie ends up dead that seems far
more likely to me in terms of something
that's gonna stick for a prosecutor I
guess the third option is was it
justified this seems the least likely by
far to me you know the if the crime is
being accused of his nonviolent and we
don't even know if our burry committed a
non-violent crime then that wouldn't
justify killing right nobody nobody
would suggest that probably people think
that these two guys were overstepping
they should have waited for the police
to get there so probably that's not
going to work okay from a national
political perspective none of this is
the primary question I think most of the
discussion of the armory killing ends
there was it murder was it manslaughter
was it justified he had an arrest record
none of that is the point okay this I
actually don't really want to talk about
the Arbour EK s-- I think the Arbour EK
siz a local very sad local story a
talk about the fact that we're talking
about the Arbour EK s-- why are we
talking about this there were 53
homicides in the United States every
single day why this one why did this one
blow up is the big news story of the
weekend it's because it supports a
left-wing race narrative LeBron James is
the king of this LeBron tweets out we're
literally hunted every day every time we
step foot outside the comfort of our
homes can't even go for a damn jog man
like WTF man are you kidding me with
like seven exclamation points and
question marks no man for real are you
kidding me five exclamation points
I'm sorry Ahmad rest in Paradise and my
prayers and blessings sent to the
heavens above to your family then it's a
prayer hand than it's a black power hand
then it's a red heart
hashtag stay woke hashtag profiled cuz
we are simply black than to cryin faces
that's not true what he tweeted out is
not true Bron James is not hunted down
everytime he leaves his home the
statistics are clear there is no
epidemic of racist White's hunting down
innocent black guys in the United States
it doesn't happen you can look at the
statistics it's not true on top of that
on this specific case we know of very
few people how many people could you
imagine in this country would support
the unjust killing of a man very few
people
the reason stories like this get
attention is because they are
exceedingly rare so what's the takeaway
here the takeaway is this is a very sad
local story that is made into a national
story to push a left-wing race narrative
and we should not fall into the trap of
encouraging that I almost wasn't even
going to talk about this because I don't
want to encourage the left making a
spectacle out of these sad local stories
to push a narrative but I think it's
important because you've got to be aware
when the left does it every time the
left is
pushing some story like this a story
that is obviously very emotional very
sad very dramatic but again local not
indicative of broader trends not
relevant to questions of national
politics or international politics every
time they're doing that it's because
they don't want you to be looking at
another story
[Music]
[Music]